foreign
let's go up to uh Baltimore and talk to
Kevin what's up Kevin
hey Dr John how are you I'm all right
brother how are you
um pretty horrible but um I feel very
fortunate that um I'm able to speak to
you today so oh man let's let's get into
it what's up
so I'm 23 years old and um I've been
gambling on Sports since I was 12.
um
it has ruined every aspect of my life
shattered everything
um and you know I'm I've listened to a
lot of your stuff and you know I've I've
done a lot of things to try and put
myself in a position to get better
um I've gone to GA I'm still going to GA
um I've seen a therapist that
specializes in this kind of thing
um
but I just can't kick it man and I'm
feeling I'm just feeling more and more
defeated by by the second by the minute
by the day so
um just hoping that maybe you can give
me any wisdom or or just advice to maybe
help me out
yeah man I can hear it in you
know most people say that you sound
exhausted
yeah that's yeah
are you you sound way past tired you
sound exhausted
yeah I also haven't slept in
um
since Sunday really maybe a few hours so
it keeps me up all day and just makes me
hate myself more every day so I'm just
in a bad spot there you go
um are you coming off anything
um no what do you mean in terms of like
drugs or alcohol yeah do you use
no I I don't drink or do any drugs at
all so gambling has just always been
been the thing what what how did this
become part of your life
yes so this is the the real sad part is
just that like
um hey hold on hold on I'm gonna stop
you there
like you and I are friends now and I'm
gonna at least while you're on the phone
with me you're not gonna talk about
Kevin like that anymore
okay that you're sad that you're a loser
and that everything sucks you're not
going to talk like that anymore
okay okay that's a choice to put on a
like a like a black trench coat of
weight you're right that you don't need
to carry is that cool yeah yeah so tell
me we'll get into all the nitty-gritty
all the guts and blood and all that
stuff yeah but at least when you're on
the phone with me you're not going to
talk to yourself and talk about yourself
that way is that cool all right I
appreciate you checking me on that yeah
so um 12 12 years old what was going on
in your world
so so I was never really like the brains
of the family and sports were always my
thing I was a great athlete you know I
played all all the sports and
um so I guess when I was there I think a
freshman freshman High School my friend
had an older brother that was like a
bookie that would take bets and um
that's like really how I you know kind
of got started I mean I was basically
gambling with lunch money then at that
point but wow but yeah I mean you know
ever since then it's just it's just
gotten worse and you know I've gone I've
gone days I've maybe gone a week or two
but you know for the past literal decade
I I have not been able to
successfully stop for any long period of
time and I'll also say that you know for
the past decade I haven't been making a
concentrate effort you know to fully
stop but right at least for the at least
for the past year or two man I've I've
been grinding so hard and I know it's
people just say just stop like what's so
hard no I'm not seems that simple but
I'm not going to tell you that that's
Madness yeah
um but seriously just stop Kevin just
stop I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
yeah um yeah
oh there's so much here okay there's a
couple things I'm gonna walk through
with you would you be willing to talk to
a buddy of mine
I would talk to anyone that would love
that would like to talk to me absolutely
would you do it this morning this isn't
like a gotcha move but I'm gonna talk to
you through a couple things
um but there's somebody that I met via
um Instagram of all places and who's
walked a journey and he's about a year
and a half ahead of you on this
um yeah if I if I invited him into this
conversation would that be cool
yeah absolutely okay it'll be a little
clunky because we none of this is
planned or prepped or anything but um
here's what I want to I want to start
you with what have you tried to stop how
have you tried to stop
yeah so
um I've my parents are extremely
supportive
um and that that makes me kind of feel
even worse just because I continue to
let them down but um they can see you
know they can see all my money um they
can see what comes in and what goes out
um like I said I've been to GA
um I've self-excluded myself from
casinos but that doesn't really stop you
from going in there it's just kind of
like a a thing that you can do that is
supposed to help but unless the security
person recognizes you in there and sees
that you're not you're not you know that
you're you're you've self-banned they're
not going to do anything so yeah
um and you know the the the part that
sucks is just that like with sports
Femme specifically like there are so
many offshore books the illegal like if
you want to get money on something you
can get money on it you know that's just
like the reality of it yes and you know
I've tried the self-excluding I've tried
Banning myself but ultimately I've kind
of just realized like
I I I have to be like I have to get to a
point where it just doesn't even entice
me you know because it's always going to
be there I can't just exclude exclude
exclude you know it doesn't seem like
that's a viable option or it's like
somebody who struggles with disordered
eating if you're a Coke addict you can
just quit doing I mean you can stop
surrounding yourself with cocaine if you
struggle with disordered eating you've
got to make peace with food because you
can't just avoid it right exactly and
you you've nailed it you are living in
this weird little sliver of history when
you have virtually unlimited access to
credit to money and virtually unlimited
access to gambling and now that with the
last four years we just stuck in your
cell phone right we put in your pocket
yeah you don't have to you don't have to
go anywhere right exactly um yeah so at
some point here's what I'm hearing
I'm hearing a guy at War
and I've never met anybody ever
Who quote unquote defeated
their addiction
yeah I've never heard that I've never
heard a guy or or a woman who defeats
alcoholism
I've heard somebody take a knee and
submit yeah and you get the difference
there it's a totally different way of
doing life yeah and I was going to say
too one of the things that like actually
scares me the most is that there's a guy
in um in the ga that I go to who's been
clean since 89 and he says every single
time that he's just a day away like
anyone else from stepping into a casino
and gambling and I just think I know
he's saying that to make us feel like
you know like we can get through it but
to me it feels like if I have to live
with this like for the rest of my life
like how I I don't know if I can do that
like like he's one day away like am I
always gonna be one day am I always
gonna feel this like because I I can't
live like this man I can't listen you're
not gonna feel what you've got right now
no
the dial the dial turns back
right
yeah
um
like
dude I want to hug you so bad I should
give you a hug man well now I just think
too like you know there's just so much
stuff that goes into this and I just
think like
like I just feel like I've been robbed
of every Joy like my dopamine is just so
cracked out from all of this gambling
that like if I can even get to a point
where I can stop like am I ever even
gonna find Joy like you know it just
feels like an uphill battle to even stop
and then I feel like okay once I get to
the top like am I even gonna be happy
like is anything even gonna change or am
I just going to be robbed of the one
thing that at least brought me you know
dope you know you know what I mean yeah
totally yeah yeah I don't know about
dopamine hold on hang on the line here
I'm gonna bring
um I'm gonna bring Craig up hang on one
second okay
okay
Craig are you there how's it going Dr
John I'm good my brother hey
um this is so just so everybody knows
this morning early this morning I I was
checking the just my calendar today and
I looked at the show notes and I saw
this was this call was coming Jenna had
sent these in
and so Greg it's the first time you and
I have ever spoken person but we met via
Instagram when you reached out and over
the last year and a half you have just
I mean you've changed every aspect of
your life in a in a profound way man so
it's a it's such a gift and an honor to
hear from you over the last year and a
half as you've changed everything and um
I appreciate you I just reached out this
morning it's like hey this is a
curveball would you mind jumping on a
call with me this morning so I man I
appreciate you going for it dude
this is uh what I've learned is a part
of uh giving back so um I was happy to
do that and um I'm grateful that was the
same I was the same person
633 days ago wow so you you've heard
this you've been on the on the line
since Kevin started talking tell me how
familiar this sounds to you
um it sounds exactly like me at 23 only
I'm 43 now okay and I wish I had the
guts and courage uh for what he's doing
now
um but I will say this 23 year old Craig
would have not been ready to stop
um I only stopped
when I was absolutely ready and uh for
me it was just the right time the right
moment the right place
I was uh desperate just like him I think
it was December 28th or 29th I was at my
Wit's End and I was
emailing you or messaging you on
Instagram and I just was pouring my guts
out and I never thought that anybody
would even read it or or look at it and
a couple days later you got back to me
and you said one thing that stuck with
me
and that made me realize
that I needed help and it was that you
cannot do this alone
and my whole life since I'm 10 years old
I was trying to do it alone and that's
when I finally reached out for help
and then here you are man you just sent
me some pictures of your wedding a few
few weeks ago man so walk us through
you've you've I mean you've paid off
like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt you're cleaning your
whole life is changing
that is correct um for me the biggest
thing
uh was connection
um
my uh gambling brought me to isolation
and just wanting to be alone and uh
forgetting what it was like to be a
human and when I listened to you and I
said when you said that you couldn't do
this alone
I started research and help I found an
online support group and through that
online support group I actually found
two gentlemen in South Florida that are
now my mentors that I speak to every
single day and I even visit them and One
Mentor had 50 has 52 years in the
program he's number 14 in the world of
being a clean from gambling his name is
his nickname is Spa bracelets and the
other guy's name is sake and they've
been with me every single day since day
three
and for me
it was about letting it out having
someone to talk to
um not being ashamed anymore getting it
off my chest
um two guys that have been there before
and uh understood it because only
another compulsive Gambler is going to
understand another compulsive Gambler so
Hey Kevin you're there
yeah so here's what I'm hearing the
difference between what you're saying
and a guy that's a year and a half ahead
of you or two years ahead of you okay
is you're going to the meetings
you are interacting with your family you
are trying to fight this thing
but you're doing it completely and
totally by yourself
do you get the difference
I think so yeah or let me put it this
way you can go to the you can go to
meetings
and be surrounded by people
who say we love you Kevin welcome Kevin
and you can feel completely and totally
alone
oh yeah that's that's to a t yeah
and there's something
um different about going to a meeting
and then doing what Craig did sitting
across from somebody and saying I'm in a
mess help
which is and that's what you're doing
today actually you're reaching out and I
would say you've gone to a therapist
y'all are trying to fix things you're
trying to stop gambling
yeah that's different than
help
and if I could um I'm sorry I don't know
Craig hop in uh here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna step out and I want Craig you
talked to Kevin and Kevin you talked
back to Craig here for a minute
hey Kev there's a place online it's
called
gamblers and recovery.com
um it's 24 hour meetings from around the
world you can find a meeting every hour
on zoom and I was just like you I
actually during the pandemic I I had to
do I probably did three four or five
meetings a day in the first 90 days just
just try to stay away from a bet and
having that kind of access
to people with that kind of knowledge
and who have been around
um just helped me tremendously I'm not
going to say it's easy it is the hardest
thing I ever had to do in my life
by far the hardest thing I ever had to
do in my life and I heard you talk about
like your joy and your dopamine I was
you times 20. and I'm and Dr John knows
some of the numbers I was you times 20
just 20 years later and you're gonna be
me in 20 years
if you don't figure this out now
yeah you have a chance because you're
looking for help and Craig I saw some
pictures of you with this beautiful new
wife of yours are you have you found joy
in other places
that's exactly where I was getting to
[Music]
um
I was the same way even having a future
fiance and then a beautiful wife and
having a daughter who plays Sports and
who's active and engaged and a great
student none of those things at the time
were making me happy or bringing me joy
632 days later
I find joy in those things again it does
subside does it go away no
no if I was somebody like you gambling
12 14 hours a day you know insane
amounts of money had no business doing
it because of access to lots and lots of
credit same exact stuff but it does
subside but it takes time it takes a lot
of time and it takes a lot of patience
and it takes a lot of effort and a lot
of work but it's worth it
so Kevin what are you hearing what are
you
feeling
I mean it's
you know I I know damn well like how
hard it is but to hear that for you that
it does get better is something that I
think is really resounding to me just
because
sometimes I even like look around the
room like in GA and stuff and it just
seems like people are just even people
that have kicked it you know it just
seems like every day is like such a
battle I guess it is always going to be
that way but here's someone you know
reclaim a lot of like joys in their life
and just I mean you seem like a happy
person like just speaking to and that
okay I go weeks on end I go weeks on end
now well it's not even thinking about
gambling when I thought about gambling
24 7. I I I was like you I started when
I was 10 years old fixing
football pools in my Catholic school
with my best friend to a lady I'm not
even I started fixing football pools at
10 years old and then my land I'm gonna
share this and I'm not embarrassed my
last bet and my money doesn't mean
anything in the program but just to give
you an idea of some fixing football
pools at 10 years old so my last bet was
27 000 and I have no business gambling
twenty seven thousand dollars
and and that's that was that 32-year
experience so it was just like a drug
addict I just needed more and more and
more to get the same exact feeling that
I used to get as that kid at 10 years
old fiction football pulse
yeah I mean that's where we go that's
the same thing as me when I when I was
you know I started when I was in my
teens and 10 10 20 wins would make me
happy and and now if I don't have four
figures on on a game it's like uh
sometimes I don't even bother watching
if I don't have that much on it so hey
Craig let me hop in here Craig tell me
if I'm because Craig I know you've got a
heart out because you're you're a
teacher and you're working with people
um correct let me um
I'm gonna say something to Kevin and you
hop in if I'm off base here okay sure
Kevin
what I I've never found somebody who
successfully hates themselves out of bad
behavior
I've never found somebody who's able to
shame themselves into making
um long-term life change ever
so here's a way I want you to look at
this for the next few months
um you're 23 so you don't you don't have
a kid do you
no I don't okay there is something so
insanely maddening and weirdly beautiful
about having your kid wake up in the
middle of the night and come running
into your room
and say Daddy I'm sick and then barfing
on you it's dude you gotta understand
it's the worst you're dead asleep and
now some kids barfed on you and there's
something poetic about
that kid came to the one place he or she
knew to go to and they weren't okay and
that's me
and so I want you to stop thinking of
yourself as if if my kid came running
into my room and stuck their finger down
your throat and was like Hey Dad haha
embarked all over me that's a totally
different story that's the way you're
talking about yourself and so I want you
to imagine for the next six months the
next year the next six months I think
you're sick man
and you're not a bad guy you're not some
sort of dysfunctional shameful idiotic
you're sick
and the antibiotic here is going to be
other people
and if you will reframe I suck I fail
I've been trying to this thing for 10
years I've been fighting this thing
you're taking a very athletic approach
to it I will conquer I will will myself
through this
um like very David Goggins I've never
seen that work with addiction I've only
seen it I'm sitting down I'm looking at
another human being and saying I'm not
all right
yeah doctor I was the same exact way and
you're never this isn't like a program
or something that you graduate from
um you don't get any graduation and what
I've learned is
um you're not going to beat it you're
not going to conquer it it's not going
to go away you're going to arrest it
though and you can you can arrest this
disease
sometimes one minute sometimes 10
minutes sometimes an hour
sometimes a day at a time and then with
time and patience and work
you can get to a point where you're not
thinking about it 24 7 and you're not
thinking about it for days and then
you're not thinking about it for weeks
and you and you can get better
all right Craig Craig I know you got to
run what do you say Kevin I was going to
say I think part of the issue too is
just that like I have like an amazing
girlfriend and she knows that I'm NGA
and she knows I have a problem but I'm
always just afraid to share day to day
how terrible I'm feeling just because
you know like not that it makes me a bad
person like you said I'm sick but like
this is something that ruins a lot of
relationships you know and marriages and
I just think like damn if I'm completely
open and I'm completely honest am I
going to ruin relationships when people
realize how Kevin you know what that is
that's shame right there
yeah that's shame that's all if somebody
actually knows me will they still love
me
and that that is the gasoline in the
engine of addiction
because at the core you believe no if
they really knew me she would not love
me and I call bullcrap on that I think
it's a lie too it is a lie and so that
when when Craig says you got to do the
work that's the work is living a life
with no secrets yes you have to be open
and honest to be able to beat this thing
you have to yeah all right Craig I know
you got to get to class man hey uh
uh it's an absolute honor thank you for
being brave
I appreciate it my my mentor told me you
better get your butt on that thing and
give back
good for him good for him hey I'm
grateful for you um I'll connect you to
Via uh direct message is that cool
that's perfectly fine all right man see
you Craig
all right uh uh Kevin
you still there Kevin
yeah okay
um
thank you for doing that by the way no
you got it is there you've probably had
several conversations like that and I
know they're not panaceas and I know
they're not they can't fix everything
um
Your Voice Sounds different now than it
did at the beginning of this call
yeah I think so too
so I want to
um this is like the part of the movie
when there's the Montage and someone
like starts lifting weights and Rocky
music's playing in the background I
don't want to blow over
if you are serious about getting well
the next three months are going to be
hell
there's just no way around that and he
said it at the beginning of the call you
have to decide am I ready for that am I
ready for three months of hell
and if you are man awesome All In
and if you're not make peace with not
being ready to go through hell
but all of the trash talking that you do
to Kevin is is not it's not helping
either side of this Cedar totter right
it's not making you a better Gambler and
it's not making you a well or human
being
yeah right
I think two is just I've found that
depression just goes so hand in hand
with addiction and it just seems like
absolutely dude you know even if I like
I was telling you earlier I'm just
skeptical about hell if I can go three
months without this is my life even
gonna have meaning and everyone that
I've talked to like the like the guy you
brought on say the same thing it does
get better it's just so hard for me to
believe with the way I feel but I got it
I guess I just have to trust what
everyone's telling me
can I ask you a hard question
yeah have you been right yet
no no
so let's let's try so let's let's try
something different
yeah our feelings have one job and
that's to get us to the next day it will
even smoke a cigarette today to deal
with today's stress knowing it's going
to kill us tomorrow
and for whatever reason
your body is associated I need this fix
right now even though I know it's
killing me tomorrow
it'll get me through right now
and the goal is to create a little bit
bigger Gap and he said it he said it
beautifully sometimes that gaps one
minute I'm gonna hold my breath for 60
seconds and get through this impulse
yeah I'm gonna attack somebody I'm gonna
call them I'm gonna get on that whatever
website he just gave you I'm gonna get
on there I'm gonna get on there I'm
gonna get on there it's I'm talking 60
Seconds
and it makes me feel terrible I know I'm
talking bad about Kevin again but it's
like you know it makes it gives me so
much guilt to put people that I love
like with this because I did it all
myself man I don't have a terminal
illness I don't I don't have something I
can't control okay hold on hold on now
you're back to morality
and we're going to take morality off the
table you're a brave dude
we're taking morality off the table
you're sick man
yeah and you don't want to believe
you're sick you want to think that you
can just flex your way through this and
you can't
yeah there's no way there's no way
and you you're also too smart for your
own good quite honestly
I know I mean I have so many friends
that are in the same position and they
have no idea they're even addicted it's
just like they're they're norm and they
don't even here's what you're gonna have
to do here's here's every single person
who struggles with addiction I've ever
met struggles with you're gonna have to
find new people to be around yeah you're
gonna have to find new communities
you're gonna have to find new things to
do when you get stressed out or angry or
enraged or heartbroken
yeah you're gonna have to breathe
through these Seasons man and it's just
here it is it's a set of skills you play
sports before the first time somebody
told you to I don't know shoot a
basketball you had to learn how to do
that that's what you're doing man you're
learning a new set of skills
and the more you can keep an open hand
towards these new sets of skills versus
trying to close fist around it
um man the the gentler the ride and the
ride's not going to be gentle
yeah right
so it'll be worth it
cannot imagine a scenario where it's not
worth it
yeah and like you like you were saying
earlier I keep thinking you know about
how you said you know if you're ready
for the next three months it's like I'm
gonna have to be ready at some point
because it's it's gonna kill me by
itself if I don't you know you can do it
now
or you can do it in jail
or you can do it in court uh Court
mandated rehab
yeah but you're gonna do it right yeah
so here's all right here's my promise uh
I'm gonna connect you with um offline
I'm gonna connect you with Craig if
that's somebody you want to reach out to
as a resource I also am committed to
um
I'll put you on anytime you want to come
on and let me know about your journey
okay thanks man that means a lot and if
you have um a great month and then you
fall off the wagon all right
you're still my friend
all right I'll still pick up the tab
just come hang out and if you have two
months and you're and you're doing all
right awesome
if you have three months awesome and if
your girlfriend wants to call into the
show and say how do I love somebody
who's struggling I'd love to take that
call too okay
yeah I'll help you every step of the way
I can hang on the line here I'm gonna
send you a copy of on your past change
your future on me just a book to say
okay here's what what's happened I've
got to own what I did period
now what
I'm gonna walk with you my brother thank
you so much for your bravery and a big
shout out again to Craig for reaching uh
for taking a last second call this
morning
um if you are struggling with addiction
can't do it by yourself
and you're worth peace